Dokka the capital of Bangladesh
it's home to wretched poverty endless
traffic and one of the fastest growing
financial services anywhere in the world
it's called be cash setting up a B cash
account is free all you need is a mobile
phone and 100 million Bangladeshis have
one transactions cost so little services
like money transfers and electronic
payments are suddenly affordable that's
why the Gates Foundation is a B cash
investor banking this cheap can change
lives in a country this poor well
banking is is more fundamental than I
realized
and there have been attempts
microfinance groups cooperatives but the
transaction fees were always too high
until we get those services down with
very low fees on to the the cell phone
in digital mode then banking will only
be for those who are better off CEO
Kamal Kadir and his brother Iqbal
founded be cash in 2011 they had five
million dollars profits from a previous
startup and a plan to bring mobile money
to the unbanked this is the country
which has two hundred billion dollar
economy right now okay
the country was growing so it's not that
it's only only charity it's it's pure
Economic Opportunity from two million
accounts at the end of its first full
year in operation usage has exploded to
seventeen million and Counting workers
who used to take time off or hire agents
to carry cash back to their villages can
now wire it instantly with a few
keystrokes imagine a canoe because say
I'm the salary pied-a-terre mother am
Davos the very day that mother Ani
Twitter Rebecca Sultana works in quality
control at this t-shirt factory in Dhaka
she makes about $85 a month that garden
my biggest tender money towards the body
cash out to what the bodies of the to
presume I'm delighted with anybody and
we can break and take my research about
the body
a German women of the Kennecott or any
dish will be that be cash isn't just for
money transfers its a payroll system a
mobile wallet and a savings account all
digital all affordable all regulated by
the central bank do you worry at all
about monopolies 'im be cash is by far
the fastest growing of these mobile
service providers we really thought
about it so that's why we have given
about twenty eight licenses to the
twenty eight banks we want few more to
come up but it's a regulatory kind of
you know hand-holding you know on the
streets of Dhaka be cash is everywhere
the company has more than one hundred
thousand agents across the country
withdrawals or how it makes money they
cost one point nine five percent the
Gates Foundation initially saw be cash
is a case for charity and gave it a
grant then in 2014 it became an investor
I actually think the cash is probably
our best investment there's such a clear
alignment between the success of the
business and the goals of the foundation
in terms of reaching for people we're
not going to reach the number of people
here by just giving away money if Kamal
can build a business and if we could put
money behind this great entrepreneur
with this great idea and business plan
and our ability to reach poor people
here is just dramatically different it
doesn't happen very often a company
improving life for the poor and drawing
praise from philanthropists while making
money at the same time be cash turned a
profit in 2014
now Kadir has even bigger ambitions
loans insurance may be an international
expansion she can sell her thread on
this thing she that we depend on on some
middleman and somebody will be seeing it
somewhere in the world okay
so that is the most powerful thing that
is happening here and and we are just
seeing a tip of the iceberg